foreign
welcome today we have a super
interesting topic to discuss
how to enable organizations to unlock
their sensitive data for purposes of
secure collaboration
it's me Rene colga product manager on
the confidential Computing team here at
Google Cloud later on we'll also have
Brandon Taylor CTO of monitago join us
here as well so what's our agenda we'll
start off with the inter introduction of
our confidential Computing portfolio
then on to the main topic launch of the
confidential space that enables secure
data sharing and collaboration
we'll have a quick demo and then one of
our great customers monitago will share
the use case for confidential space
but before I get started let me ask you
an unusual question would you be
comfortable sharing your salary with
your colleagues or classmates would you
be comfortable putting your salary on a
piece of paper right now and giving it
to one of your colleagues and then
asking her to do the same for you
probably not right but today we'll show
you how you as well as your organization
be able to do it in a secure manner
using the confidential space solution so
let's get started
what is confidential Computing anyway
well it completes the end-to-end data
protection story
Google always provided automatic
encryption for data at rest we also
enable data and Transit encryption
capabilities but what about data in use
prior to confidential Computing there
wasn't really a way to protect data and
AI models while they're being used
so confidential Computing strengthens
the data protection story through
Hardware powered encryption of memory
confidential Computing provides
mitigations from hypervisor
vulnerabilities Rogue admins user space
attacks and various memory attacks
how does it work
if we look at the typical Cloud compute
setup logical isolation is provided for
VMS out of the box
with confidential Computing in addition
to that logical isolation we add strong
cryptographic isolation and integrity
capabilities
all provided by the CPU here you can see
a secure processor that creates
ephemeral keys for each VM those keys
are rotated at every VM Boot and they
are non-extractable from Hardware even
Google doesn't have access to those keys
it's also important to note three things
about our implementation of confidential
Computing here at Google Cloud
first it's ease of use it literally
takes a single button to enable
confidential VMS
no need to rewrite code or recompile it
anything that runs on a regular VM
should run on a confidential VM
next one is performance our customers
typically see near Zero Performance
impact when they enable confidential
Computing obviously your mileage may
vary as it highly depends on your
workload and last but not least
scalability today we support instances
for up to 224 vcpus and almost a
terabyte of memory 896 gig to be precise
our confidential Computing portfolio
today includes confidential VMS
confidential containers through our gke
offering secure data processing through
confidential dataproc and many future
confidential Solutions are in the
pipeline
so what are the benefits of confidential
computing
obviously confidential Computing is not
a silver bullet however it provides you
with another security lever for your
Cloud deployments especially for
organizations with highly sensitive data
it completes the end-to-end data
encryption story
it helps demonstrate due diligence for
compliance purposes and finally it
enables very interesting
integration data sharing and
collaboration use cases and this last
point is exactly what I want to focus on
next
Unfortunately today many organizations
are having to pick between
innovation
and maintaining user privacy or between
improving disease detection and
protecting their patients Healthcare
records or between improving customer
service experience in retail and
protecting financial and personally
identifiable information of their
clients obviously organizations want and
need both
and that's why we're introducing
confidential space
powerful way to enable secure
multi-party collaboration with trust
guarantees all built on top of
confidential computing
it's public preview for confidential
space will be available soon I would
love to tell you more about it
as I mentioned confidential space allows
multiple parties to collaborate without
having to trust each other blindly
it enables scenarios where you can gain
Mutual value from aggregating
confidential data together while
retaining full control over it
this type of privacy preserving
analytics is exactly what confidential
space can facilitate
let's take a look at a few examples here
we have a healthcare organization on the
left that wants to improve their disease
Diagnostics model and we have an AI
company on the right side that focuses
on developing such models
however they don't have enough Phi data
to train their model while the
healthcare organization may not have all
the resources to develop such model when
both of these parties collaborate they
both win with confidential space the
data owner Healthcare organization can
share their sensitive data with this
trusted execution environment in the
middle or te but if and only if it's
running on top of confidential Computing
keeping memory encrypted and if and only
if it's running the right previously
agreed upon War cloud
in the end patients when disease
diagnosis and detection improves and no
Phi data is put at risk
in another example we could have
multiple Banks focused on fraud
detection or money laundering activity
detection in this case workload author
may be one of the collaborating banks or
an independent third party
again all collaborating banks benefit
because often this type of complex
fraudulent activity is only visible when
multiple financial institutions pool
their data together
these were just a couple of examples but
we see confidential space use cases in
insurance and fintech for fraud
detection and health care for giant
machine learning training in retail and
other verticals to build and enable data
clean rooms
now let's switch to a quick demo
coming back to my question about sharing
your salary with your colleagues or
classmates in this demo we are going to
show you how to do that securely using
confidential space imagine two
colleagues on the left who have Alice
and on the right is her colleague Bob
they agreed on a code that would rank
their salaries without revealing the
actual numbers
would generate an input file with her
salary just over a hundred thousand and
Bob will do the same on his side on the
right with a salary of exactly 100 000.
next they will encrypt those files
Alice will do it first on the left
here we'll also run a headstump to show
that the file is indeed encrypted
Bob encrypts his salary data as well
then the encrypted files get uploaded to
their corresponding storage buckets of
our collaborators
in this example Alice is the workload
author this could have been an
independent party as well
Bob audits the workload prior to
collaborating and is able to reproduce
it on his side to ensure its legitimacy
Alice already milled and uploaded the
docker container with the workload that
will rank their salaries but note to
show the actual numbers you can see its
sha 256 hash here
this is the same hash that Bob adds to
the attribute conditions within his
workload identity pool which is the
definition of his policy it defines
under which conditions Bob is okay
releasing a key to his encrypted salary
data
in this example his policy checks for a
number of things including the type of
the confidential Computing technology
required like AMD SCV version of the
hardened OS where the workload container
will be running the authorized user and
the image digest our hash of the
workload itself
Alice also has a similar policy but does
the workload author she doesn't need to
include the image digest instead she
includes the workload location in the
artifact Repository
in our demo Bob also plays the operator
or admin role and runs the workload that
Alice built however that could have been
an independent third party admins can
only start stop workloads but they are
unable to access data in clear text or
influence the workload in any way
foreign
the workload is now done and Bob will
read the output
this output is of course accessible to
all collaborators
let's see what it says
oh snap it looks like Alice is making
more money it's time for Bob to ask for
a raise
now let's imagine that Alice goes Rogue
and instead of just learning where she
ranks among her colleagues she wants to
get their actual salaries
so she as the creator of the workload
modifies the source code to include
salaries in the output file
she then rebuilds the docker container
and pushes it to the Repository
as a reminder Bob's policy includes the
hash of the workload under the attribute
conditions right here
now we'll get Bob to re-run the now
modified workload and let's see what
happens
okay the workload completed and Bob will
read the output obviously Alice could do
the same as the output is in plain text
and meant to be shared among all
collaborators as we can see from the new
output file we received an error stating
the given credential is rejected by the
attribute condition it means that Alice
wasn't able to take advantage of her
calling Bob because his policy included
among other things the hash of the
previously agreed workload when Alice
modified it the hash obviously changed
that's why the workload didn't leak any
sensitive data such as the actual salary
of our collaborators
this is how multiple parties can share
sensitive data and collaborate in a
secure manner
so I hope you enjoyed the demo in
summary confidential space provides an
ability to collaborate without blind
trust everything is measured and
verified before you give access to your
data
providing you with data confidentiality
data Integrity as well as code Integrity
guarantees you retain complete data
ownership you control
how your data is used and which
workloads are authorized to access it
and again you don't even need to trust
the operator or the admin
now I would like to pass it on to one of
our great customers monitago so they
could share their confidential Computing
and confidential space use cases
Brandon over to you thanks Renee hey
everyone Brendan Taylor here CTO at
magnetico magnetico is a leader in
financial services technology providing
the only Global fraud prevention
solution against duplicate financing our
mission is to make working capital more
accessible to the millions of
underserved businesses by reducing risk
in trade Finance magnetico's secure
financing product has been in production
since 2018 and has recently been
launched globally in partnership with
the Swift Network to make it available
to all major banks around the world
our problem is simple in nature but
complex to solve businesses get various
forms of loans secured against
receivables or inventory they own
the problem is that it's very easy for
these businesses to go to more than one
bank and get more than one loan against
the same set of documents this would be
like you taking out multiple mortgages
from different banks against your home
what this boils down to is that because
banks have no effective way of sharing
sensitive information between themselves
billions of dollars are lost each year
to fraud
this is where we come into play our
secure financing platform provides a way
for banks to share this sensitive
information without breaching their
customers privacy
our product has two core pillars to it
firstly deduplication where we compare
every document submitted to identify if
it is suspiciously similar to another
document already submitted
second authentication which aims to
identify whether the documents provided
are actually genuine or not
so what makes this a difficult problem
to solve well it comes down to trust and
privacy
firstly banks have to give us their
customers commercially sensitive data
but also they have to trust that other
banks will not be able to gain any
insight into their business
so how do we provide guarantees as to
the protection of this data and their
privacy
like all businesses that deal with
regulated and sensitive data we
Implement isms policies to address
identified risks
but the route of trust for these
operational policies ultimately relies
on good behavior of employees
the truth is Insider threats through
either negligent or malicious behavior
represent the most significant source of
security breaches at tech companies
what we need is a technological solution
to minimize this risk
with Google's confidential Computing
offering we took one step closer to our
goal initially magnetico is leveraging
confidential gke to ensure protection of
data whilst in process however since the
data is stored with monetigo it must be
equally protected at rest
while there is no easy way of
implementing trustless data storage we
Implement a multi-key encryption process
to ensure no single individual can
breach security
for Phase 2 the introduction of
confidential spaces will enable us to
take the next step by giving the option
to our customers of storing their own
sensitive data within their own secure
accounts the data kept client-side can
be pulled on demand into a permissioned
confidential workload on magnetico's
accounts for advanced analysis the
results of which contain no sensitive
data and can be shared back to the
relevant parties this creates a similar
Paradigm to client-side encryption for
secure enclaves with verifiable privacy
guarantees through attestation meaning
our customers can rest assured that
their data can be safely processed by
minetigo with a greatly minimized risk
of data breach even from internal
threats
the value that can be unlocked through
the adoption of multi-party computation
globally is profound whether it's saving
countless lives by being able to learn
from pooled medical data or helping an
entire industry eliminate systemic
problems such as fraud through
Collaborative Learning in a competitive
environment we are excited to be a part
of the evolution in this space and look
forward to continuing with Google on
this journey now back to you Renee
in closing I would like to thank you for
attending and leave you with a few key
points
confidential Computing is an
industry-wide effort in Secure Computing
and we at Google together with oems are
working and innovating to further our
privacy and security guarantees
confidential Computing provides
hardware-based data encryption and
remote attestation it's easy to use
performant and scalable
finally confidential space Builds on top
of confidential Computing and enables
new use cases like secure data sharing
privacy preserving analytics join ml
training and much much more
I hope you try out our preview and thank
you very much for attending
[Music]